Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
July 30th,
2018 what's going on?
How,
AH,
yeah.
Um,
I'm a little bit late here with this podcast.
MMM.
You know,
I was out there in Houston,
Texas for two nights in Dallas for one
and I want to thank everybody that came out and uh,
the weather was great.
It wasn't that hot,
you know?
I mean it was hot,
but it wasn't like Texas hot when we flew into Houston.
I saw,
you know,
a nice green fucking grass in that shit.
I didn't realize Houston was right on the water.
I always thought you still had to drive like an hour before you get to the Gulf
of Mexico.
I don't think I ever looked at that.
And I know a lot of [inaudible]
[inaudible]
no,
I didn't.
I didn't want to watch a bunch of people losing their houses.
Did you watch it with your fucking popcorn before there was that disaster?
Did you know that it's sat right on the Gulf unless you live there,
that's actually,
you know,
something.
Every time I go to a,
um,
a state,
I kind of look where everything's positioned and it's so fucked.
How like your brain remembers it.
That guy always thought Austin was inbetween Houston and San Antonio turns out
it isn't.
It's north,
just northeast of San Antonio on the 30th.
And then like a,
you know,
fucking San Antonio,
Houston are kind of parallel with one another.
And of course Dallas is all the way up there on top
Dallas,
Texas where the heat is real and the titties ain't.
Um,
I had an awesome time when I was up there.
And guess what,
guess what old freckles has done?
He hasn't drank this whole month.
Oh,
did he want one last night?
But he didn't.
Um,
I'm going to,
yeah.
This is my new thing.
I'm drinking the way I smoke cigars once every 10 to 14 days.
If I do that,
if I do that alone,
I will cut down on my drinking by at least
172%.
Now,
I don't know what ever do,
um,
that's the game plan.
So I got a little,
uh,
little,
little Shindig August 7th.
Then I go right back on the wagon until fucking,
I'm going to try and go back on the wagon.
That's the hardest thing for me.
Once I go off a whole daddy's playing the game again.
Oh,
he's,
he's in the gang.
You get a little dirt on a beautiful.
Um,
yeah.
So,
uh,
Nate Craig was out there with me crushing it every single night.
And um,
I dunno,
don't have anything bad to say,
but I know you.
I think it was weird.
It was weird going to Dallas and not sitting in a Binya texts.
Other than that,
it was a good tam.
Um,
all right.
That just bumped me out.
Why would I bum you up?
Good News.
Hey,
you know,
something,
his taste is something that you,
you might not have known about me,
but sensed when you were in my presence is I swear to God,
if I wasn't a comedian,
I could have been a manager.
Well,
at least I could.
I could have been a talent scout,
you know,
telling you how many more do I have to call?
Remember long time ago I said,
you know,
I've been watching this drummer on Instagram at the pocket queen.
Well,
that drum is going to be sitting in with the Seth Meyers show all this week.
What did I say?
Go ahead.
Go back and look at the old podcast.
Listen to him
was right there.
I could've done it.
I could've brought the red socks out of there.
Fuck at age six,
year curse earlier.
If they had me as a talent scout,
I could just see,
no,
I can't see it in sports.
I can't see everyone at whatever you know,
you don't really is,
is you make a fucking thousand guests and then one of them comes in and then
what you really do is you just brag about it,
which is,
which is what I'm doing.
So anyways,
I'm back out here in Los Angeles.
All right.
I'm sitting in a very progressive manner.
Um,
you know,
when I watched last night,
I watched a couple episodes of,
uh,
Seinfeld's new,
comedians in cars.
You got to see the Brian Regan won.
The Dave Chappelle worn is awesome.
It's Dave Chappelle.
But this Seinfeld one,
the car that Brian Regan likes,
I actually like it too,
but it's a 2005,
like two Cedar Cadillac or something like that.
The level with,
I've met I on all the episodes.
I've never seen Seinfeld shit on a car.
Like he shat on that car
from the way it looked to the options to describing the person that was going to
drive it.
Um,
and then Reagan of course it was Reagan and he was fucking hilarious.
But I was kinda hoping he was going to bring up how much he did not care for
Brian's tastes and cars,
but you should check it out.
Uh,
if you get a chance.
So anyways,
here's my story.
So I'm in Houston,
right?
And I was supposed to fly up to Dallas and once again I fucked up.
I want to fly into love field cause that's the smaller one in Dallas fee and
whatever that fucking Metro airport,
whatever the hell it is,
it's gigantic.
But this time I actually went through Dallas airport and it was,
it was real easy.
Oh,
I know why because I wasn't connecting,
connecting through Dallas.
She always got to get on that fucking monorail.
And I swear to God,
if you're,
if you're in terminal B,
your connecting flight is in terminal a and you always have to go all the way
around.
You always miss it.
Just buy one share.
You could grab your bags and start running through the airport,
you know,
like Oj Simpson back in the day,
I guess,
you know,
maybe that's an option.
I don't know.
Um,
so anyways,
I was going to fly from Houston,
but uh,
Nate didn't get a ticket,
thought we were driving up.
So I was like,
God,
fuck it.
You know what?
I can't remember last time I took the 45 north up to,
uh,
from Houston to Dallas and uh,
canceled my fight flight.
We just fucking drove up there.
And um,
I gotta tell you,
man,
that is a,
uh,
it's an intense state.
Dallas,
Not Dallas,
Texas.
I me,
I mean,
there's just like nothing out there.
And then all of a sudden you just,
you finally fucking come on something.
You get so fucking excited,
some sort of barbecue joint.
I'm like,
maybe we should start there.
Man near the middle of nowhere.
Everything starts looking good,
looking at it and they got fireworks.
Let's pull over,
man.
We've got to get some of those.
I haven't seen anything,
any signage,
civilization for the last fucking hour.
Uh,
but we ended up stopping at this gas station with it.
They got this checklist of archaea and a Slovakian.
I don't want to start the fucking wars over there.
Um,
little,
uh,
dessert thing that they have that some people put meat in.
Some people put fruit in it or whatever.
And I only seen him in Texas.
It's usually when I'm on the 35,
right around Waco,
Texas.
Um,
I was joking about that guy all weekend.
You know,
Joel Olsteen.
I was teasing those people down in Houston going like,
I can't believe you guys were surprised that that guy didn't let you into his
house when the hurricane cave.
You know,
he's,
he's selling out a basketball arena,
talking about Jesus.
Do you think this guy's even remotely honest on any level?
Let's do that thing where I have my eyes closed going.
Jesus doesn't want you to step on my blue rug.
I'm
talking about David Koresh anyways,
as I was named David Credit.
Really good looking guy,
man.
You remind me of that guy that who started in California Californication
he's also written,
uh,
um,
the x files.
David Duchovny Sorta David.
Do companies sort of understated by with them with like Richard Gere's here
or was that I got more of a Rambo here current,
you know,
I gotta look it up.
No,
but like if you could go back in time,
we got hey to the cops right before they'd go went nuts.
Amen.
You got to get this gay scene.
His Jesus.
Well,
I see look like,
ah,
you know,
he kind of looks like a,
let's go Rambo haircut like David Duchovny would just a splash or Richard Gere
sounds like a cover of people magazine.
[inaudible] know.
Um,
what are,
what are you looking up David Koresh?
The K factor.
He definitely would have got the plane ticket to Vegas.
They'll get the guy,
you know what I mean?
If you tick off those fucking Glenn,
he looks like he could have done the Bjorn Borg story is what's going to freak
me out.
How long did this go live from?
1959 to 1923 Oh,
Jesus
was,
he was 30.
Oh,
he's 33.
You know those Jesus freaks,
that's when they like to die.
That's when they like today.
Oh Gee is died at 33.
So if I fogging die too,
then that means I'm just as his father or to make no sense.
I thought it was gonna come out on Sun anyways.
Um,
so I've been eating perfectly the whole weekend and then I stopped and I got a
couple of those,
uh,
with,
I didn't know what the fuck they're called.
Checklist servo hammers.
I'm going to get you the name of them.
I can't find it.
It was called like a collage or something like that.
What the f come on there it is.
Kol a c h e.
Oh my God.
That does the delicious.
Hey Nia.
Wait,
who is that?
Hey.
Hey Buddy.
Oh,
you've got your book.
Do you want me to read your story baby?
Oh,
is it?
Hi Buddy.
Can I get kiss?
Nah.
All right.
Oh,
the boss baby.
Do you guys like to listen to old freckles Riggio kids book.
Oh,
you didn't?
Okay.
I don't touch that.
Don't touch that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Thank you.
I appreciate you showing me that was there.
Yeah.
I have to do a podcast,
man.
I don't know if I could do this right now.
All right.
From the moment the baby arrived,
it was obvious that he was the boss.
Yeah.
He looks like he put mom and dad on the round,
the clock schedule with no time off.
Thank you.
Does this seem familiar,
Kiddo?
Um,
bombing with arena and then he set up his office right smack dab in the middle
of the house.
She's not even listening to me.
I have like no charisma here whatsoever.
She's finding the crap on my couch.
Way more interesting.
He made demands many,
many demands.
You've got a little Trump suit on and he was quite particular.
No,
I like that.
If things weren't done to his satisfaction,
he had a fit mount.
Sounds like these parents need to pooch kick them into his crib.
He conducted meetings lots and lots and lots of meetings.
Hey,
are you interested in this at all?
I had to get back to my podcast.
Keep reading.
All right.
Many of the meetings happen in the middle of the night.
The funky thing,
when was this written?
Marla
trasy.
Then an old black woman,
Marla.
The funky thing that came out of nowhere is it the 70s
never ever said a single word that made any sense,
but that didn't stop.
She wants to run around
like,
do you want to look at this?
I just feel like everybody's fast forwarding through this.
Whoa,
whoa.
All right.
And then daddy went back to his podcast.
The end.
Is that cool?
Bye.
Okay.
Um,
yeah,
I have to get back to a particularly excrutiatingly unfunny podcasts that have
been recording.
Anytime I start and I start like promoting something or whatever the hell I just
did out of my,
my whole brain just goes out the damn window.
Do you want me to read that book again?
Okay.
Sorry guys.
This is just part of it now.
The boss,
baby by Marla phrase,
from the moment the baby.
All right.
Let me get back to this.
So
bye.
Bye.
I love you.
Yeah,
there you go.
She can't sit.
She just goes and Yang,
Yin and Yang.
Um,
she,
yesterday after,
uh,
I flew back from Dallas,
um,
I landed at lax and I met a friend of mine,
believe it or not,
um,
who owns one of those Vietnam era fucking helicopters,
the Huey ewh ones.
And uh,
he was there with his instructor and they pick me up in the thing.
I literally at least sounded like I was in fucking apocalypse now.
And um,
you know,
he flew around up the coast of Malibu and all that stuff and then we landed at
the small airport,
got some lunch and then they let me fly it.
And uh,
it was amazing.
You know,
it's funny,
they,
old people always said,
if you can fly in our 22,
you can fly anything.
Um,
they are 22 is the little egg beater that I fly and it's kind of like driving a
car.
I would say with like no power steering power brakes.
You,
you're really doing it.
Um,
but despite all that,
anytime you get a new helicopter,
it's like,
it's not just like,
you know,
if you would just to like,
if someone was to like taxi it out for you and you just took off,
it's very easy to fly anything.
But it's like when you come to a hover,
you know,
and you're doing little turns and stuff and trying to set it down on the pad,
I don't know.
That's when I sit there thinking like that,
you know?
Okay,
you might be able to fly it,
but I don't think you can maneuver it.
Well.
So,
uh,
we just did it some pad work and then I flew from a
camera ratio all the way out to,
uh,
to Burbank.
It was amazing.
It was fucking amazing.
And,
um,
I want to thank my buddy for letting me do it.
Not naming any names or any of that crap that was speaking I helicopters.
Everybody keeps telling me I've got to see that new Tom Cruise mission
impossible.
Doesn't it seem like my podcasts lately that I'm subtly throwing in advertising?
I swear to God I'm not.
I watched that movie.
Uh,
okay.
the,
uh,
the death of Stalin yesterday on the plane.
Jesus Christ.
I don't know who,
who the hell wrote that man?
How do you turn that guy into a comedy?
But somehow they did with those fucking hilarious,
um,
two of my favorites of all time.
Uh,
Steve Buscemi and Jeffrey tambor all run it.
They are absolutely hilarious.
And I wish I knew the name of the,
one of the other lead cronies there.
MMM.
It's fucking amazing movie.
This,
this fuck.
You know what it is?
I don't have my fucking headphones.
I don't have a microphone.
I just,
I'm,
I,
this is,
this is like,
this is like Kryptonite.
You know,
I'm under the fucking gun.
I gotta go fucking meet somebody.
I've got,
I got no time.
We'll feel maybe if you want to drive and flying around and fucking amazing
helicopters,
you a whole and recorded this yesterday,
we wouldn't have listened as mediocre shit.
Um,
hey,
this week I'm going to be at rough and rowdy,
rough and rowdy brawl.
August 5th is podcast is nothing but promotion in fucking.
Um,
what the hell am I going to be in a Youngstown,
Ohio?
You can preorder the fight@roughandrowdybrawl.com.
Rough.
The letter n rowdy brawl.
Dot Dotcom.
Uh,
they got a pride verse prejudice.
They have a gay pat is going to be fighting this ex felon who doesn't like gays.
That's the,
uh,
that's the title fight.
And then we have a cop fight in a skateboard.
Um,
you know,
and then there's also a bunch of a bunch of Cleveland Brown fans and Steeler
fans that want to beat the shit out of each other and it's all done in the name
of fun.
How do you not sit and watch that man?
It's a,
it's like a tough man compe competition,
but with stories,
you know,
and it's really never reading the kind of people that you could,
you could,
uh,
the match ups with how much people don't get along.
You know,
you could have neighbor,
verse,
neighbor,
uh,
yeah,
you get in the gay community,
you could go with ex boyfriends and girlfriends,
you know,
cause then it's still check on check guy on guy,
right?
Um,
bearded ladies.
I Dunno.
It's,
it's endless and I can't wait to go,
but right before I do that,
or the day after assumption,
I'm going to be in Rochester,
New York home of Steve Gadd,
uh,
with,
with Dean del Ray coming off play marbles performance up at the just for laughs
festival.
MMM.
Anyways,
uh,
I can't,
you know,
something that's the first time ever,
I'm actually starting to feel my God damn age,
you know,
and I was in Dallas,
the fact that I had like two shows and I wrote up sitting down in that frigging
car,
I'm telling you,
you know,
I was like going like,
it seemed like I was had to go shovel somebody driving.
Once I get out on the stage,
I'm fine,
but,
um,
actually I'll probably find the whole time,
but I'm just like,
uh,
just the thought of it.
Two shows never bugged me.
Three was always like,
all right,
what the fuck?
What am I working in a mine here?
I thought I'd got into show business to have a nice,
easy fucking life here.
MMM.
Yeah.
Just spent like feeling my age.
So I gotta get back to a,
I don't know what you know,
cause I shouldn't be feeling,
I used to feel a little bit in my fucking nose on my,
my shoulder's fine and now my knee is fucked up.
I don't even know what the Hell I did to it.
Just crawling around,
playing with my daughter.
All of a sudden just my knee all of a sudden
felt like really?
I don't know what hot stinging pain,
but it's not constant and it's only when I put pressure on it.
So I don't think that it's bone to bone.
Thank God.
I don't think I'd been active enough to have that shit.
This is one of my favorite things to do,
by the way.
Just to let you guys know what some of my ailments are and then you guys all
just turn into doctors is one of my favorite thing though.
Do you know what that is?
It's actually your kidney.
Hear me out.
One time there was this guy right?
And they just fucking goes into that shit and he was out on the golf course.
You guys,
you know,
I'm gonna have the doctor look at my,
my knees.
And the next day he died of a,
uh,
a kidney apparatus,
kidney,
uh,
aorta.
What'd they call it?
Kidney Hemorrhage.
Camera's [inaudible],
I'm sorry.
It was eight.
That fucking little checklists of Aki and dish.
And then,
then I went right back to salads and I was fine and find a file and then late at
night,
these goddamn hotels,
they always get me,
they always had the little snack thing I'd eaten.
Perfect.
When I was in Houston,
an unbelievably,
there was no snacks right now everybody knows Houston was voted,
uh,
unprecedented.
Back to back.
They went back to back.
Is the fattest city in America.
Okay.
And this is no,
you know,
sound like these are,
this is some little fucking,
you're not going up against cupcakes here in America.
No Pun intended.
All right?
Okay.
We use some of the fattest people on the planet.
I don't even think we are.
I've got to be honest with you.
Maybe we are,
but collectively,
well,
when you're in the cities,
you know,
you don't see a lot of fat people.
You're in the city.
There's just too many eyes on you.
You know,
you get out in the country,
man.
I mean,
shit,
you can just walk you property fucking butt ass naked.
Who gives a,
you know,
nobody cares how fat you get.
And those overalls,
we'll,
we'll hide the,
the first 40 pounds.
Who's kidding?
Tow.
Remember Uncle Jesse,
that big goddamn beer belly he had,
but he had an the overall,
so you look,
you look like Santa Claus.
Just a good old boy.
Never in no home.
Mm
is dumb.
Explore the booze and fucking regret.
He doesn't even know his kids.
Um,
was that what that whole thing was about?
He was uncle Jesse.
Beau and Luke were cousins.
He must've come from a big family because that should have been odds out.
We should have been one of their dads.
Right.
Cooter
is crazy.
Cootie catcher ears on.
Um,
I'm actually at the end of the sixth season of a 77 sunset strip.
It got canceled after 20 episodes.
And,
uh,
I'm really gonna miss that show and I hope that me TV,
which I'm going to look up right now is going to go back to episode one again
cause I missed it.
They start,
I could have watched the whole series since last November and I didn't even know
it was on.
Um,
and I would love to and I really wanted to see those first five episodes cause
he was in la anytime they weren't in La,
I would always hit pause just to see,
uh,
if I could recognize where they were.
There we go.
Meet TV 77 sunset strip.
Come on man.
Give me a fucking showing.
Gimme a showing schedules that one 77 has its roots in an underrated,
I don't care about that.
Come on,
let's schedule.
Watch.
It's going to be over.
I'm sorry.
We have no listings of that weeknights at 4:00 AM,
but are they going to start over again?
But you stopped.
I didn't get one on Thursday or Friday,
Thursday or Friday.
So,
um,
let me read some of the advertising hits.
We,
I,
I got nothing for you here this week guys.
The red sox speak to twins.
There's something,
we've got the Phillies tonight for some more exciting inner league play.
They have inner league play like every fucking two days now.
You know,
they always go,
they always got to kill it.
The Yankees dead fucking big man there,
Aaron.
Judge Way Guy fucking chipped a bone in his hand.
You know,
it hit him right in the palm to mass,
got a fucking killed,
you know,
you know sometimes like chip in your elbow seems like,
well it's kind of sticking out so it wouldn't hurt that much.
It's designed for that.
Like,
you know,
the inside of your palm,
but chip that as far as like the worst bones to break his another one cheekbone.
Yup.
Begging file that into fuck that.
Uh,
you want to break your neck?
You can break a toe.
You know what I mean?
Why do you think that they were torturing you and they wanted you to give up
where the base was?
You could handle a broken toe,
right?
Ah,
I was so bad.
I'm still not telling you
fuck.
Yeah.
You know,
once the,
once the guy goes to the rusty tools though,
it's,
it's like,
all right man,
what are we doing here?
What the fuck do you want to know?
I don't give a shit.
What are they going to call you?
Let me go.
I tell you,
I know you're gonna kill me.
Let me just tell you where everything is and you just take out the drill.
Hey,
smiley.
Oh,
the itsy bitsy spider went up the water spout.
I ain't doing you want me to read the boss baby again?
Huh?
Oh,
you're excited,
Huh?
Whoa.
Oh,
whoa.
Bye.
See you later.
All right,
let's show off here.
Okay.
Uh,
laughing.
Crying.
Angry.
Surprised.
There you go.
Good job buddy.
Where's your toe toe?
You know that word,
honey?
I have to read advertising here so I can keep buying you food.
Huh?
Keep buying food.
Yeah.
That's how it works.
Come on.
All right.
Oh,
look at this first one,
honey.
Whoa.
There we go.
Oh,
it's okay buddy.
I'll be out there in a minute.
Oh my God.
Oh,
she's holding her arms out.
just holding her arms out looking at me.
Oh boy.
Okay.
And now I have to continue podcasting under these circumstances.
All right,
first read of the week,
honey.
Millions of people are using honey to save money while shopping online.
And why wouldn't they?
It's very hostile.
It's free.
Takes just two clicks to add to your browser and save you time and saves you
tons of money.
It's ingenious,
but one of my absolute favorite things about honey is how much better it makes
shopping on Amazon.
Um,
please personalize.
Personalize this to make it your own honey Madge.
Okay honey.
A magically adds all sorts of useful information on the Amazon page of whatever
you're looking at.
Oh,
supposed to buy my supposed to make this personal just shop like I normally do,
honey.
Honey,
honey automatically searches the 2 million sellers on Amazon to find you the
lowest price.
It even shows you the items,
prices changes.
So you can decide if you want to buy or wait for the price to come up and down.
Then I read the right.
It even shows you is the,
the item's prices.
Prices changes.
Its price changes.
Honey,
read it right.
If you do decide to wait,
just add it to honeys,
droplets,
and it will notify you if the price drops when honeys got your back.
You'll never overpay for anything on Amazon again.
There's no reason to not to add honey to your browser today.
It's free and takes just two clicks to install and we'll make sure you always
get to the lowest price on Amazon.
Add honey to your browser for free right now at join honey.com/burr that's
joined honey.com/ [inaudible] in note cheap.
Talk about how every man looks better in a suit.
Listen,
nobody checks out the fellas like me,
okay?
I put on my glasses,
I sit on a street corner and I just waited for them to sashay pat and I gotta
admit,
I find time and time again,
I'm just attracted to a man in a suit.
It's confidence,
it's success.
It says,
I'm going places.
Take my risks.
Honey.
Um,
Indo Chino is the world's largest.
Why would you take as risk?
You take his arm right is the world's largest made to measure men's wear company
and has been featured in major publications including Gq,
who Forbes,
ah,
and fast company.
She keeping fast company.
They make suits and shirts made to your exact measurements for our great fit.
Guys love the wide at the wide selection of it.
The wide pants,
you know,
fat clientele,
guys love the wide selection of high quality fabrics and the option to
personalize all the details,
including your lapel w uh,
lining and monogram.
You've got to have a look pal.
You know,
when you're wearing a suit.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Have to have a lapel just in case you disappoint somebody and they need
something to grab.
Here's how it works.
First a showroom or shop or shop online@indochino.com pick up your fabric,
choose your customizations to submit your measurements,
wait for your custom suit to arrive.
And just two weeks.
Uh,
this week my listeners can get any premium Indochino suit for just 379
dollars@indochino.com I n d o,
c h,
I,
n o,
all capitals.com when entering bar at checkout,
that's 50% off the regular price for made to measure premium from a to measure
premium suit.
Imagine if I did this on vinyl and just got stuck may to Majia made to Madhya
plus shipping is free.
That's indochino.com promo code birth for any premium suit for just $379
including free shipping,
including incredible deal for a suit.
They will fit you better than anything off the wreck ever could.
All right hotel tonight,
honey,
we have to fuck now.
Thank God there's hotels and hotel tonight is the Goto App for booking great
deals at great hotels.
Unlike other hotel booking sites,
hotel tonight doesn't have long,
endless lists of a zillion hotel choices instead hotel tonight to night to
night.
Oh,
with a well shows you the best deals at best hotels.
They partner with top rated hotels to help them fill their unsold rooms,
which is how you get such great deals.
And even though the name is hotel tonight,
it's not just for tonight.
You can book tonight,
tomorrow or beyond.
It's perfect for planners as well as procrastinators.
When are you gonna be in town,
honey?
I can plan for the future.
You can book spontaneous weekends.
Three day,
three day.
You get a fucking threesome.
Getaways,
staycation,
road trips,
business trips.
You can dress up like a nurse.
You can book a hotel,
you just so you can use the pool,
et cetera.
Download the hotel tonight app today to get great deals at hotels you actually
want to stay at.
And with Promo Code Bar you can get $25 off your first eligible booking hotel
tonight.
Promo Code Berg.
How many more of these?
I got to read.
All right,
three down.
Three to go.
We'll do one more and then I'll give you a break.
All right.
What are we getting?
Blow row?
No,
they're not selling assets.
Owning a couch from hell is like a rite of passage.
I eat too expensive,
too heavy,
too cheap to warn.
You.
Found it on a street corner and God knows who fucked on it.
Uh,
police use one of your negative couch experiences to contrast.
How amazing your new borough conscious.
Oh I used to live with Robert Kelly back in the day and uh,
I think Bobby Watch Sanford and son too much because he was constantly bringing
things in from the sidewalk.
One of these was a couch that he then put a bed spread over,
which was I guess supposed to block out the potential body lice or maybe broken
cracked pipe that you could sit on.
You know,
you know what,
you know what I really wish
other than that I could hug Bob Right now and tell him that it was okay that he
took that couch off the sidewalk.
I really wished that burrow existed back then cause me and Bobby could have
fucking ordered a couch right after all these years of suffering.
Was that personal enough?
After all these years of suffering you owe it to yourself to experience the
comfort and quality of a borough couch.
Borough borough brings style and comfort to a whole new level and ships to your
door fast and feed your relationship with your couch will never be the same.
I always slept.
You burrow sofas are era grenache likely designed.
So I'm comfortable while I uh,
what do you do most on borough?
Not off while watching me TV cause I think you know it's most comfortable while
I not off to TV.
Customize Your Borough Sofa to match your style by selecting the colors,
size,
armrest,
height and led color,
armrest side.
Wow,
that's brilliant.
Shipping is fast and free unlike the rest of the future industry.
And did I mention it has a built in USB charger.
Wow.
This is sounded like you could take this thing to space.
Enjoy 30 days of cozy on your comfortable borough risk-free or try it out
borough at one of their partners show rooms today and then what?
You can bring it back rows customized or it say that,
oh you can try it for free for 30 days.
Customize your own borough and get $75 off your order by going to
borrow.com/x x,
x,
x.
Oh,
I guess that's supposed to be bear.
I was like,
I know.
It's was like,
that's a weird one.
That's B U R r o w.com/x x x x.
No bar.
Fuck for $75.
My fucking Ron Burgundy.
God dammit.
He'll read anything there.
Slash Burger I should say for $75 off your purchase borough makes the luxury
couch for real.
Okay.
All right.
Let's get to some of the questions for this week.
I guess that's what we'll do.
We'll do a couple of questions and then we'll fucking go back to some more
advertising if I can actually figure out how to read it.
All right.
Russia feeling left out.
Hey,
you bill burr off.
Uh,
I've been listening to you tell you talking about your upcoming Eastern European
tour in the latest podcast,
but not hearing about any stops in Russia leaves me quite scarred and
traumatized every time the podcast ends.
Is this guy making fun of millennials or how soft Americans are,
or are millennials a worldwide problem?
I mean,
what's the deal with leaving us out?
Stand up is very popular here right now.
Stand up in Russia.
I mean,
are you allowed to talk about anything?
I can't see going over there and doing a Vladimir Putin fucking impression?
Could I?
Then what happens?
All of a sudden somebody sprays some mist on me and I'm sure you can easily pack
a full show several times over in places like Moscow and Saint Petersburg.
Uh,
besides think of all the experiences you can have in the Oji Vodka capitol of
the world.
It's dirt cheap with the current exchange rates.
The cities are beautiful and quite different from what you see anywhere else.
The people are friendly,
welcoming,
and fun loving.
Was this written by the KGB or is this really a regular person?
You never know.
I mean,
we haven't gotten along for a long time.
I know it kind of died down for a minute,
but you know,
it's always going to be Yankees and red sox with us,
unfortunately.
Um,
to be honest with you,
dude,
I'm actually,
I was talking to my agent about trying to add Moscow,
um,
which I shouldn't have said because now everybody's always trying to add it.
And then if I don't,
then I'm a fucking asshole.
Um,
anyways,
he said,
I know we have a bad rap currently even heard you mentioned that gay people and
journalists have been killed here,
which would be laughable to us if not so many people believe those stories.
Uh,
oh,
you don't think,
oh my God,
am I who's living under the right media bubble?
Anyways,
but let me ask,
just ask you one thing.
If you're so skeptical about the media in your everyday life,
why go around and believe what that same media is spewing about other countries?
Not Saying you should take my word for it.
Come and see for yourself.
Hey,
come on over,
Bill.
We're not killing anybody over here.
Grab it.
Make your own decision and the meantime,
give a little gift of laughter to melt are cold my strike chef loving hearts.
I don't even want to say have a nice day and go fuck yourself.
Oh Man.
Um,
no,
I would love to fucking go over there and,
uh,
I dunno what the fuck the belief,
but I do know this a,
we're not the only one's lying,
you know?
Okay.
It's don't believe the American media,
but believe my media about my country.
Well,
I guess maybe I should believe.
I mean,
look,
I don't think I would if I went over there.
Yeah,
it would be honest.
I don't know.
Maybe you're being honest.
Who the fuck knows?
You know,
I think we should just grow up and joined forces.
Um,
okay.
A R P oh,
hi bill.
[inaudible] I've heard on your podcast that you,
oh wait,
by the way,
have you guys seen the Vladimir Putin fucking goes out and plays hockey and they
just letting them score right and left.
I got a fucking post that video,
you know,
that's that type of shit.
You know what I mean?
Like,
do you think they'd let Donald Trump score?
They probably would,
but we always had that thing.
Oh,
they're not,
they're letting them score cause they don't want to get sent to Siberia.
Um,
a a a p hi boo.
Hey,
you know something,
I would like to hear from more Russian people.
I want you guys to infiltrate my fucking podcast here.
Like you did the last election.
Oh,
a hot take.
I don't even know if he did that.
Um,
[inaudible] I have no idea.
I don't pay it.
I don't watch the news.
Um,
a R P hi bill.
I heard on your podcast that you received a r p invitation to join.
The biggest benefit we get from arp is that it is a very large lobbyist for us.
Old People.
Please join.
Thanks.
Oh my God.
Did I just joined a group?
Um,
yeah.
For those of you didn't listened last week.
I turn,
uh,
I'm 50 years old now.
Mooc makes me qualified for Aa,
our P and I can,
I can go to the movies for like $8.
You know,
I can get a custom cane walking cane or something if I want.
There's a whole bunch of things I can do.
Um,
I'm actually,
you know what,
I was on the road and I saw there was an email.
It was something I needed to fill out.
Okay.
Um,
anyways,
plowing ahead further.
You know,
I gotta be honest with you guys,
I'm always honest on this podcast.
Last night,
yeah.
Had this little square of fucking weed and she goes,
take a bite of it.
I got,
I hate eating wheat,
I don't like eating.
And she goes,
no,
just try as,
I don't know,
I don't want to do.
So she talks me into it.
I'm eating dinner and I ate the fucking thing and I never really felt anything
in about 10 minutes ago on this podcast.
All of a sudden fucking hit me like 12 hours later,
you know,
I'm not like fucking tripping,
but I think that's why I was reading like x,
x,
x twice instead of once.
I have no idea.
I thought this shit is supposed to make you like clearer.
I,
I really Miss Booze.
I mean,
you just kind of know what's going to happen.
Like what,
what's going on right now is just like some Bruce Lee shit.
It's my brain swell up now and I just keel over on my own podcast.
Um,
anyways,
nutrition.
You goofy baldheaded bat baldheaded potato look and Fuck Jesus Christ.
Your heart shit in the mail,
man.
I know you are looking to go to a nutritionist for advice.
Be warned.
This industry isn't particularly well-regulated.
Yeah,
I know,
I know.
It's terrifying.
Basically once they,
they have that degree,
they don't have any oversight like real doctors.
If they fuck you over,
there's only so much that you can do.
Well I could sue them.
But you already saying they don't have the money of a doctor.
So what's the point?
A here's what you should do.
A find a nutritionist that provides advice based on lab work.
Most of these cuts we'll just have you keep a food journal and then give you
advice based on what you ate over the week.
This is stupid and it can be both misleading and inaccurate.
Not to mention expensive
lab.
Finding the person that provides advice based on lab work.
Well,
I mean it's can't you just fucking sit there thrown out stats.
Quarter five doctors recommended this is barriers.
Um,
anyways,
be whatever product they get you to start taking.
Ask them if they get money for the referral and what are they gonna say?
Yes,
I'm a good nutritionist.
Won't try to sell you something just because they get a kickback and an even
better one.
We'll give you a list of options of things you can do based on your blood work.
And I make this all makes sense.
I guess eight people that have to give their opinion,
give you their credentials as a means of validating their opinion.
But for context,
I'm a member of Team USA and competed in the 2006 Olympics in Rio.
Jesus Christ did fucking thrown your Dick on the table here.
The only reason I say this is that a is for the example that team USA is
sponsored by Coca Cola and even our nutritionist attempt to hook us up on
protein brand,
um,
on approaching brand owned by coke.
Yeah.
That's how it works.
Everybody has a side deal despite it being an inferior and more expensive
products.
Wow.
They recommended it to the athletes,
isn't that,
and it was,
it was gold medals on the line anyways,
just saying,
be careful who you listen to.
They even do elite athletes with this shit.
Well,
you know what,
that's probably one of the most informed fucking emails I haven't read or are
yeah,
I guess it is an email write letter.
When I was,
oh,
when I was a kid,
they called them letters.
Yeah,
I know.
I have to watch out for that.
I'm one of the reasons I got a nutrition in this.
It's is because,
um,
when I went online,
anything that I looked up about food,
I mean the whole front,
I don't know how many pages was just all big time websites and um,
and then just confirm everything was conflicting.
You know,
these are good.
Don't eat those all day.
You've got belly flat.
You know what the problem is?
Bananas.
A lot of people think bananas are fucking,
is just like,
you know,
I don't know.
I love when people do things.
You start telling you like certain fruits and vegetables are bad for you.
It's like,
yeah,
well I imagine if I eat a fucking Bushel of them,
it's not good.
But isn't there also like some sort of a potassium or some shit?
I get out of bananas.
I don't know.
Gorillas eat them.
They look pretty fucking buff.
A 23.
And me,
uh,
here's the old Billy cito.
Oh,
hey there Billy openly cheeto Dick.
Oh Man.
Come on man.
A link to the article at the bottom,
but I know you don't read.
So here's the gist.
Alright,
hang on a second.
23 and me is getting lots of money from big pharmacy.
What the fuck is this?
Okay.
And he goes,
all right,
he goes,
you were absolutely right.
This company 23 and me is set to make 300 million from sharing their users
generic information with big pharmacy.
Oh,
is that one of those,
uh,
like ancestry.com websites?
Uh,
they say it's so the buying company can use the data to develop medical
breakthroughs or some shit.
But I'm sure we all know that's bullshit except,
except to see robot replacements within a decade or two anyway,
so you could use some vindication from a fellow conspiracy nuts.
Have a good one,
and go swap your own spit.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Um,
I would actually guess that
all of that is true.
Okay.
The,
they're going to use all of that information,
um,
to develop new drugs.
I would think because they're trying to make money,
none of which will cure you.
They'll just keep you up,
you know,
on the hook.
We'll keep them all just alive enough that he keeps buying them a little pill.
Um,
and then I also think the robots are going to come.
Absolutely.
You know,
but the bottom line is,
is the people who are making the robots are overseeing it are also human.
So it's in their best interest to try and cure ship for other humans.
Right.
I already told you my philosophy right on my fucking theory was basically I
shouldn't have told you guys about that fucking stupid pot square thing.
Cause right now you're like,
oh man,
just cause he's high.
You know,
fucking people who are like into,
we'd always give it credit.
You know,
like I didn't already have this thought.
I had this paranoid thought stone sober alone in a hotel room.
This is what I think.
I think that they're going to fucking use that shit to build robots and then
they're going to kill everybody off,
keep a certain amount of people alive and their job's going to be to like keep
reproducing so the Illuminati can harvest the organs.
I swear to God that's got to be from the weed man.
No,
I swear to God,
I've actually said that on stage this weekend.
Stone sober after eating a salad.
You know,
a lot of those salads actually have chemicals sprayed all over him.
So you're actually,
I know,
I know.
There's no fucking way around it.
Alright,
Bill from a lady,
uh,
hey,
build the blahzay blahzay cunt,
the blazo count.
Um,
I'm a relatively recent listener of your podcast as if seeing you at cluster
fest in San Francisco a year ago.
MMM.
That sentence makes no sense.
I am a relatively recent listener of your podcast as of seeing you at cluster
fest in San Francisco a year ago.
All right.
I guess that does make sense.
But it was kind of written it up,
passive aggressive Shakespearian way.
You could've fucking arrange the letters a little more,
uh,
straightforward there.
So,
all right,
I'm not going to lie.
That one right there.
That was the weed.
I literally have a meeting and a half hour.
Like what the f I'm just going to fight.
I can't imagine the show I'm going to agree to do.
All right.
Not Looking where I was going.
I almost accidentally walked into you while you were on your way to interview
Jerry Seinfeld.
Uh,
most is the same lady.
I probably came off as rude from my deer in the headlight moments of literally
running into one of the best comedians of all time that I write this.
So I hope you can accept my late apology.
What am I in fucking in Lord of the rings here?
Yeah.
Is it you are forgiven.
She is spared.
I thought your interview and headliner act was terrific and hope to see another
one of your shows.
That was one of the coolest fucking days ever,
by the way.
I fucking got,
got to do a,
I do my own show that day.
No,
it wasn't.
It was a day after I'd finished my show.
The next day.
Uh,
I get to interview Jerry Seinfeld in a theater in front of,
I don't know,
couple of thousand people while he promoted the latest season of comedians in
cars.
Had a great time.
And then I walked out the door and,
uh,
had a car service to go over with Josh Adam Meyers.
We had booked a car service to go to the NBA finals to see like game three of
the NBA Finals,
um,
golden state versus the Cleveland Warriors.
And the driver was so cool.
He let us smoke cigars in the back.
C'Mon man.
Great fucking days in my life.
Anyways.
Um,
I'm glad you mentioned you wanted more women to write to your show.
I would love,
yeah.
Cause I love trashing you.
No,
I'm kidding.
I would like to hear that.
What did,
did she,
you think I would love if you had more female guests on your podcast?
Oh Gee.
I don't think I've ever had a woman on my is that need on sexist,
sexist,
sexist?
I don't think I actually appeal to women.
And I can tell you why.
Because my shows a sausage fest and when I go outside I can't even tell you how
many times somebody will be like,
it'll be a couple and they want a picture and like the wife or girlfriend takes
the picture and they never want one.
Just the guy does.
So I mean,
I don't know.
I think maybe this is just like a,
okay.
I Dunno.
I'm trying to think of something that's so strictly for guys like footballs.
You know,
basically that version.
I was trying to pick something to actually offend women.
Footballs are for everybody.
Anyways,
I was wondering if you could give me some dating advice.
Um,
society generally teaches women at a young age that men are suitors and women
are courted.
But as a 27 year old woman who dates women,
sometimes it gets particularly difficult to figure out who does what role,
especially if both women are very feminine.
Well,
at that point you've got to step it up.
Also just be a staring contest.
Right?
Sometimes these roles just fit naturally,
but other times there isn't a clear sense of direction.
And the whole thing just falls apart.
Let me ask you this.
All right.
Because opposites attract.
They always say,
mmm.
And I've dated people who are too similar to me and it's just we want a yin and
a Yang.
We would to yangs.
So we had half the fucking thing taken care of and the rest was a shit show.
So when the lesbian world,
all right,
if both women are feminine,
does that have less of a chance of making it as a relationship we want to hear
from lesbians were taking college at Fat,
fat,
fat.
Sometimes these roles just fit naturally,
but other times there isn't a clear sense of direction and the whole thing just
falls apart.
I'm also not naturally comfortable with approaching women in bars or social
events that eventually wait for someone else to make the first move.
Risa,
why you got all the power?
Because it's,
it's,
it's all women,
right?
So there's no fucking,
there's nothing to hide.
There's nothing holding you back here other than that voice in your head going,
what if she says no?
Recently,
I feel like I've missed out on some good opportunities for dates because of
this.
What advice would you give to someone who wasn't used to being the proactive or
leading role in a dating situation?
Uh,
thanks and best wishes to your family.
Oh yeah,
go fuck yourself.
Well,
why don't you just start hitting on somebody you're not interested in,
you know,
just as practice.
I just say that stupid is dumbest most over the top shit.
I mean I'm applying to this.
Two is a guy.
If you're afraid to talk to women,
it's kind of like a,
you got to see the humor in it.
You got to see the humor and getting up thinking someone gave you a look like,
yeah,
I'm in to you.
And you walk all the way over there and it turns out they were looking at
somebody else or whatever you say to them,
just completely bombs.
And then instantly in that moment,
you know,
I should just turn around and walk back to where I was.
But just out of some stupid pride,
you'll continue to stand there for 10 minutes.
No adding rather than ripping the bandaid off,
just slowly tearing it off so that person can reject you for another fucking
sixth of an hour.
Um,
oh,
she said,
ps,
I've been Vegan for six plus years and found it does work.
It does wonders for my health.
Changing my diet.
Literally cured a moderate skin condition I had since I was a child.
Uh,
if you're still curious about giving v Veganism a trust,
a test run,
sorry.
I'd say try it out for a month and see how you feel.
It definitely works for me,
but I know that's not the case for everyone who tries it.
Um,
yeah,
I'm trying to be lazy about learning how to do it.
I just like go to a nutritionist,
teach me,
you know,
I was just like,
hang out with somebody that's,
you know,
show me some of the,
just give me a fucking big,
you know what?
I wish they just had like a giant march madness,
like poster for how to be a Vegan,
like that.
Easy.
You know what I mean?
Like you look,
okay,
these two teams play.
Now,
this team's names here.
So I know it won that game.
I wish they could just fucking do that and break it down and the bracket leads
to the finals,
which is protein or at least the fucking,
whatever the fuck,
whatever else you need.
Carbohydrates.
I don't fucking know.
I swear to God.
I am literally going to sue my girl,
my wife,
a fucking drug in me here.
I can't even keep my fucking thoughts straight at this point.
Um,
girlfriends,
arguably racist family.
Oh boy.
Oh Jesus.
Uh,
I'm a black guy in Louisiana with the girlfriend who is white.
Her family is very religious and reserved as am I.
Although we are kind of religious,
her and I know our families per se,
where we have our beliefs and don't shove them down people's throats.
Anyways,
the problem is she has,
she had a kid with a black guy right before I met her.
All right.
She has a type,
her kid is not even six months.
He left her high and dry and wants nothing to do with them.
Now seeing as we are in the south,
I asked her a normal correct question down here.
Is your family okay with you dating a black guy?
That question gets asked all over the country.
By the way,
there's this myth that racism is just down in the south.
Um,
she was very honest and said,
Eh,
my mom and dad should be fine.
He eats fried chicken every Sunday.
So you'd love them.
She said that my grandparents and that generation,
uh,
not so much.
Well,
she was making,
I guess this is a joke,
this one like reading it,
you're like,
I don't know how this was set anyways.
Fair enough.
I'll work with that.
The problem is after she talked me up to her mom
and her mom saw a picture of me,
she was like,
oh no,
he's black.
You just going to get hurt.
So I don't know if her mom was just inherent
inherit,
oh,
inherited the racism or if she feels that way because of black guy ditched her
pregnant daughter.
Uh,
how do I approach this?
They live in the woods.
Jesus Christ.
This sounds like a fucking Tarantino movie.
You know,
one of those little shorts that he makes,
you know,
and going back to visit them is kind of sketchy to me and I haven't told my mom
because she'd have an aneurysm.
Yeah.
Don't go in the woods of fucking Louisiana to fucking visit some pistols.
Like get out.
Don't fuck it.
Do that.
And their kids it.
Yeah.
And the chicken.
Ah,
wait a minute.
This is get out you motherfucker.
Is that what this is?
Oh,
I've been had.
You know what?
That's embarrassing.
Anyways.
Rough and rowdy,
bro.
No,
wait,
is it,
did she get pregnant in that movie?
No.
I don't know if that's real or not.
Hey Nia,
she probably left.
Left the scene of the crime.
All right,
well I've got a couple more advertisements to read here.
Oh,
the black Tux everybody.
Yes.
Next with the black tox.
Oh,
Jesus.
Wedding season is upon us.
Oh,
they're always getting married in the summer,
right.
If they're broke ass couple of,
there's no air conditioning in the fucking church and then they're the,
they're the ones who always want to have the long fucking religious ceremony and
wedding season is upon us.
You're going to be doing it big and going out to all of your buddies weddings.
When you're bringing a date,
you want to look fresh,
but it has to be convenient.
That's where the Black Tux,
Trump's in the black tux has awesome suits and Tuxedos and all kinds of styles
and you rent them online.
The black Tux offers the kind of suits and Tuxedos styles that would normally be
why wildly expensive to buy and you might only wear it once like
the Emerald Shawl Tuxedo.
It's funky.
It's cool.
How many times are you going to wear an Emerald Green Tuxedo with the,
the black Tux you can do,
you can do you do you man and blow it out for your big one time event.
So try a new look,
do something different,
and take your style to the next level.
With the Black Tuck Tux free home.
Try on,
you can see the fit and feel the quality of your suit months before your event.
After ordering your suit will arrive 14 days before your event.
If anything is less than perfect,
the black Tux will send you a replacement right away.
And remember how simple returns are,
uh,
where Jesus Christ's almost forgot how to speak English,
where it turned heads.
Then send it back three days after your event.
Shipping is free both ways.
Stand out at your event for the right reasons.
With the Black Tux to get $20 off your purchase,
visit the black tux.com/burr.
That's the black tux.com/burger for $20 off your purchase.
The black Tux premium rental suits and Tuxedos delivered.
And lastly,
but not leastly,
simply safe,
simply safe.
These guys obsess over the details and it's why the alarm system is so good.
Here's an example.
A typical glass breaks sensor sometimes gets fooled of false positive.
Sounds like drop plates,
a baby crying.
Uh,
I was,
I supposed to like,
here's an example.
Was I supposed to like try to make a funny example?
I never know what this copy simply safe,
uh,
didn't want to settle for typical because really good home security should be
really accurate.
So they actually constructed a glass break tests facility,
all swimming breaks classical.
Okay.
Should be a break glass test facility,
class break.
They ran over 10,000 live glass breaks situations,
refining their detection technology.
It was so accurate.
It can distinguish a broken plate from a broken window.
How fucking boring was that?
And what does that some guy looking at like the,
the,
the volume,
the sequence,
the same sound wave two,
you had 500 different sounds of broken glass.
What if somebody breaks a window with a wine glass?
Honey,
sorry,
I'm not going to be home tonight.
Yeah,
I got a break.
Uh,
you know,
I got to see what happens when you frisbee a plate into some fucking stained
glass.
Um,
but you know what,
God bless these guys for doing it.
This is the level of details.
Simply safe puts into everything they do.
They're the Daniel Day Lewis of breaking glass.
It sets them apart from other security companies.
Simply saved system is designed so you'll never notice it.
Never have to think about it.
It's that.
It's that easy and intuitive.
There's no contract.
They work hard to earn your business.
24,
seven monitoring with police and fire dispatch.
It's just $15 a month.
It's the best around the clock protection.
You can find,
or do you simply saved security system today.
It's simply
safer.com and simply safe.
We'll donate one,
uh,
to a family in need that simply safe for.com simply safe bird.com.
It's an I know why and simply,
all right,
that's going to be the podcast.
Um,
from Monday,
July 30th.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.
Have a great week and go fuck yourselves.